the Russia collusion hoax has been
brought to its knees and we have much
more that will be coming in the days and
weeks and months to follow that I can
assure you the corrupt the compromise
that guy the congenital liar everything
I've been telling you about him is true
he is now facing public embarrassment he
may just not know it yet Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn has been
exonerated by the way judge Emma
Sullivan your honor where are you it's
time to let this man go free we need to
hear from you and the biggest news is
former President Barack Obama as of
yesterday has now been implicated in
what is the biggest abuse and power
corruption scandal in American history
so Barack Joe what did both of you know
and when did you know it we need to hear
from you and coming up will show you all
of the explosive new developments from
the Intel committee documents 53 I mean
hundreds and hundreds of pages of
interviews that Adam Schiff has been
hiding from the public because they
reveal all of his lies we're going to
review how the Pravda propaganda armor
the Democratic media that is the
Democratic Party the media mob socialist
state TV how they are reacting
defensively to this week's incredible
news spoiler alert the hysteria has now
reached new heights because they have
been exposed also we have a full report
on this horrific shooting in Georgia
you've seen the videotape we have a lot
of questions tonight but first we begin
on this Friday night the corrupt the
compromise the congenital liar Adam
Schiff he is a national disgrace that
even worse than I thought
thanks to Acting National Intel directly
to the Attorney General of the United
States Bill Barr we have definitive
proof of shifts malicious dishonesty in
the form of roughly 6,000 pages newly
released sworn testimony he's been
hiding from the American people this
comes from the Intel committee's 2017
Russia investigation these are the
interviews that were taken under oath we
have a complete timeline of shifts
unethical behavior is outright lying on
all of the media and we begin let's
with the date July 17 2017 it is on that
day that Adam shift listen to Obama's
Director of National Intelligence that
guy in the middle James clapper and he
testified under oath saying quote I
never saw any direct empirical evidence
that the Trump campaign or someone in it
was plotting or conspiring with the
Russians to meddle with the election on
October 13th same year Adam Schiff heard
from Obama official Samantha power who
testified she has no evidence of
collusion quote I'm not in possession of
anything on September 8th 2017 Susan
Rice telling Adam Schiff quote to the
best of my recollection there wasn't
anything smoking and I don't recall
intelligence that I will consider
evidence to that effect on November 3rd
2017 former Deputy Attorney General
Yates Ali aides concluding to Adam
Schiff there was no evidence of
collusion but on March 13 2018 just four
months after those four officials and
others testified there was zero evidence
of any Trump Russia collusion the
congenital liar shift got in front of a
camera and of course not questioned he
was held up as some kind of hero by the
mob in the media the socialist Pravda of
our day had said there was significant
evidence of Trump Russia collusion he
knew it was a lie he had all the
testimony proving it was a lie but this
is what he told the American people take
a look the American people need to know
whether the Russians still have
something they can hold over the
presidents had the President of the
United States so our work is far from
done I can certainly say with confidence
that there is significant evidence of
collusion between the campaign and
Russia now let's not forget there was
only one guy who thought he was talking
to a Russian and that was chef and you
have a guy that was pranking that's
right Adam she thought is a real Russian
we have compromising material Trump
what's the nature of the compromise Nate
naked pictures at that time they could
they could pictures does Vladimir know
yet but the core Adam in no compromising
immaterial and I'm Apollo that's him on
tape
thought he would he thought he was
colluding with a Russian he thought a
year later by the way March 24 2019
their shift repeating his lies as he had
all throughout this time period all over
the media they never ever challenged him
they were they were giddy with this
welcome back congressman thank you so
much for joining us we appreciate you
thrashing Trump what news do you have
today what lies did you tell us and they
let him get away with it this time
ABC News take a look you have said
though in the past there was significant
evidence of collusion how do you square
that with Robert Muller's decision not
to indict anyone and there is
significant evidence of collusion and
we've set that out time and time again
hey George you got to call him out for
the lie you're gonna invite him back and
say why did you lie to us and get this
on April 7 2019 after the Muller report
found new evidence of Trump Russia
collusion that was the fourth
investigation shift continue to lie for
investigations he's still lying he goes
on fake Jake news tappers Sunday show
that nobody watches and said that there
was ample evidence of collusion
this is why it's CNN fake news and why
people chance CNN sucks
take a look what I've said on your show
and others Jake for over a year now is
that yes there's ample evidence of
collusion in plain sight but that is not
the same thing as proof of a criminal
conspiracy beyond a reasonable doubt
that is the guy that represented the
entire Democratic Party in the House
Intel committee Russia Russia Russia
Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine a proven liar a
disgusting sociopath and the congenital
liar shift he damaged this country with
all of these lies one of hoax after
another all his conspiracy theories the
mob and the media you people in the mob
you are his willing accomplices you've
been his dupe the whole way lie after
lie
Russian lies Ukrainian lies ship show
lies and he's leading this party and the
mob into what are uncharted waters that
literally threaten the constitutional
order of this country just take a look
at this creepy looking lunatic
who will do and say anything to smear
slander besmirched Donald Trump and
thrust himself of course into the lights
of the cameras in the limelight this
lying that you just witnessed it is only
the tip of the iceberg for example I
could go on the whole show November 15
2017 Schiff defended Hillary's bought
and paid for even the New York Times now
recognizes likely Russian disinformation
from the get-go because the Russians new
chip new steel was feeding it to Hillary
they were helping Hillary they were
creating the chaos Devin Nunez warned
Obama and Biden about in 2014 and they
didn't listen to and he said that much
of the documents meaning the dossier had
proved true that was another lie
December 19 2017 taurima cave sworn
testimony
the former deputy FBI director could not
point to one single claim not one this
is McCabe one not once in Steele's
dossier that he knew was true and
accurate and all of that is in this
document dump yesterday but thanks to
Rick Grinnell and attorney general Barr
in fact he also testified McCabe did he
didn't know if the steel material on
Carter page he didn't know if any of it
was true none of it was true
this was the material that was used
starting there in October of 2016 as the
basis for four separate FISA
applications even McCabe admitted in
sworn testimony no dossier no warrant
they said it wasn't true it's in his
testimony in February 2018 Shipp
authored a memo claiming there's
absolutely no PI's abuse whatsoever
despite congressman Devin Nunez who told
the country the truth Schiff lied Nunez
told the truth warning to the country
Nunez was telling all of us the truth
this guy was telling us lies even when
he had testimony that was telling him
they were lies the DOJ is inspector
general he was telling the truth
Steele's dossier was Russian
disinformation all along shipwide two
socialist comrades in the Democratic
Party they helped him lie and the
mob in the media acted as his PR staff
this is a revolting but clear and
present danger that remains to our
constitutional republic the rule of law
equal justice under the law equal
application of our laws they must be
held accountable the dossiers contents
were not verified he knew he was lying
they told him it's not true it is a
disgusting despicable revolting lie by
the biggest liar we've ever witnessed
even Christopher Steele himself he
couldn't stand by his own dossier as
we've been telling you in an
interrogatory under the threat of
perjury in Great Britain
so you have this corrupt compromised
congenital liar Adam Schiff not only a
national embarrassment this what he's
doing is a threat to our national
security and he was helped and literally
the mob and the media and his fellow
Democrats are complicit and they were
complicit every step of the way instead
of working to combat government abuse of
power and corruption shift chose to
bolster his own publicity at the risk of
innocent people whose lives were
destroyed instead of upholding his oath
of office he lied again and again it was
a coup after tamp conspiracy theory to
unseat a duly elected president and by
the way after they couldn't prevent him
from getting elected because we the
people didn't listen to them he lied
about an innocent man protected those
who were truly guilty
they worked together they coordinated
now make no mistake history will not be
kind to this pathetic idiot from
California's 28th congressional district